probabilistic flavor also some
discrepancy phase and then we'll have
the open problem session yeah
first talk is a very and thank you very
much for the invitation so I will talk
about the cumulants which is like the
combinatorial approach to probability
but let me first use some slides to give
some introduction to free probability I
suppose that X is here somewhere experts
around here so what is the framework the
framework is instead of looking for sig
modulus we have algebras and instead of
having expectation we have general
linear functional so here we care more
about the random variables which will be
elements in my algebra and we have a
linear functional which since the
identity the unit in the algebra two one
and this is just to make it a
probability measure so we will typically
have some further structure meaning that
we will have an adjoint and we will talk
about positivity meaning that that would
be positive if it can be written as a
star a and the functional will be
positive it said positive things to
positive
area is that we want to think this as a
conjugate the transport conjugate of a
matrix and what is the typical algebra
is that we work with because we went
some topology when we will work
basically with sister algebra which are
just bounded operators so in this
framework we can talk about the moments
of a random variable so the idea is that
we get information of my random variable
through how the linear functional acts
on powers and this is what we call the
moments of a random variable just like
expectation of X to the K is the usual
moments and this is how we can associate
a measure to a random variable well we
you say to measure the distribution of
my measure of my random variable is the
unique measure whose moments are the
moments of my random variable of course
this in the general framework may not be
unique but if we are in sister algebra
and is bounded then we can be sure that
and this is self-adjoint we can be sure
that actually there is a real measure
which satisfies decided ok and here is
what I mean that if you want
probabilities here when we put K equals
0 we want this to integrate 1 that's why
ways we assume that Phi of 1 goes to 1
so and all these ideas come from this
framework comes from quantum mechanics
basically where this functional here is
just the packing vector
okay so typical examples of course we
won't want to generalize classical
probability and here I should emphasize
that we are losing information because
we don't have realizations I mean in
meaning we don't have events where is
looking on distributions and random body
but not not really on the bins so this
generalizes in some sense but not in in
the general sense that we can get
probabilities from this another
important framework is for this this
talk is matrices n by n matrices and
here the functional that typically we
use but this is not the unique Nick one
is the normalized stress and I use
normalized so that we have identity goes
to one of course I can combine these two
and I get random matrices here the the
usual in a functional that I consider is
combining these two meaning I take trace
of the expectation or expectation of the
trace and these are of course also
satisfies the property that one instant
over here the unit is the same unit yes
for matrices and what are the
distributions of course the usual
distribution in probability is the
probability
I defined in four matrices this is just
the so-called spectral distribution or a
gamma distribution so this is a
distribution with put maths one over in
to each of the eigenvalues when the
matrices say normal or Salvage and four
random matrices we don't get a random
eigen value distribution but we averaged
over all of them okay so this is not a
random object this is for a random
matrices this is a fixed object which is
the so called I will check in value
distribution typically in application
one studies this distribution and then
uses concentration of measure to show
that actually the random eigenvalue
distribution a is very close to the
average
we have another more algebraic example
and somehow we're free probability came
picture comes from the group algebra so
we have the group algebra which is just
the finite sums of element in the
algebra with context coefficients a and
the linear functional tells me what is
the coefficient of the identity in the
group so I have here a son and I use
care about what is these coefficients
for and of course you will think that
this doesn't give me a lot of
information but if I consider powers of
o of this element then somehow I will be
able to recover most of the information
of the coefficients that I look it
depends on the and the important
observation is that if I have two groups
and I consider the the group generated
by words on G 1 and G 2 so I mean the if
they are the free group generated by G 1
and G 2 then the linear functional
satisfies this property that for any
element in in the group algebra that has
a coefficient 0 on the identity and for
any families that satisfy this then if I
make the product when this age are in G
1 and this v-star in G 2 then because
there is no relation there is no way
that I can get a coefficient in the
identity okay and this is somehow this
observation says is that if I take
alternating products of elements which
are indifferent which have mean 0 then
the product will also be half say mean 0
and this motivates the definition of
McCullough school and what this is
telling us is that if we have algebra
switch cover somehow have no relation
between them then this should be
captured by the linear functional in
this way and in fact this is an even on
leaf for the group so two groups are in
free position if an all algebraically if
and only if this satisfy this relation
which is back to the functional that I
defined and ok for two random variables
we said that they are free if the
algebras are in free relation and just
to mention there are many many many many
development of this theory like the
limit theorem infinity visibility
stability processes even entropy many
analog things I move for this talk the
first important result is called central
limit theorem and there is a big
difference here is that of course we
normalize and we don't assume that they
are classically independent both free
independent then we get the semicircle
distribution which is bounded so very
different from reaction and in fact
there is improvement of this theorem one
of them is a result by which Ambika
let's go where they actually show that
for large end this one is absolutely
continuous the densities converge
uniformly to the density of the
semicircle and also the support provided
that the original measure was bounded
the support goes to the support of the
semicircle distinguished
which is of course not the case say - is
not the case in the classical which is
called super convergence and another
result this is analog to the classical
case is that we also have a variation
bounds meaning that the distance of this
on Mollison with the semicircle
distribution can be bounded by some
numbers which depend on say the fourth
moment and of the arrow of order 1 over
square root of it
we just mentioned that in this context
maybe it's important that the example of
free products of graphs so the free
product of graphs is let me just put an
example we start with with rooted graphs
here I chose lines and then I put one
graph and then in each vertex I put the
other graph and then in each vertex I
put the other here I wanted to emphasize
that if I consider these copies of my
graph embedded in in the free product
actually these guys are in federal Asia
mean isn't not only that the
distribution is the free convolution but
actually that as operators with respect
to the vacuum vector they are free
or free dependent
you know your example is this one and I
just want to mention that as it was
observed yesterday of course there are
no new cycles and he's very different
from crepitation products were actually
lines to wit line gives degrees which
means make a lot of cycles
also maybe the example that it's
important is of course the D regular
graph which comes from taking n free
partition free product of the of the k2
with itself
okay and direct consequence or
corollaries of course the central limit
theorem for the triple graphs which says
that this converges to the semicircle
normalize
tracing
so now I will talk about what is a free
cumulants so free commands were
introduced by Bakula school say
analytically and then visited by Spiker
in the combinatorial
way ok
so calculate the convolution so we need
the so-called Cauchy transform which is
just expectation of the resolvent and
then they are transform is just given by
the compositional inverse of the Cauchy
transform - and taking one pole in zero
the way that we can analytically
calculate free convolution is just by
adding there are transforms so this is
the analog of the logarithm of the
Fourier transform in classical
probability and okay there is something
similar for for the convolution which is
called the for the multiplicative free
convolution which is called the S
transform and what we want is so so you
see thing is if we have actually the
moments are captured by the coachee
transform somehow if we want to
calculate the moments of the free
convolution the formula becomes very
complicated so we want numbers which
have the same information of as the
numbers that have the same information
as the moments but that somehow behave
nicely with respect to addition of
random variables okay so we will have
three properties that the first property
is somehow saying that they have the
same information in that if I know the
first end moments I know the first
increment and vice versa the second
property is that it behaves well when I
multiply by a constant and the till one
and probably most important important
one is that if I have independent random
variables say freely independent or
classical independent or any
independence then they should be
additive and with these three properties
actually I can prove a central limit
theorem for any notion of independence
that I have provided that my random
variables have all moments who is very
very simple
so consider just another normalized sum
of random variables killed it should be
and let's calculate v cumulants just to
so the first cumulant so the central
limit theorem suppose that that first
command is 0 and second cumulant is 1
just to normalize ok then the cumulant
of the sum of these random variables
normalized so this guy goes away by N to
the one half and then I add our
cumulants which are 1 because they are
have the same distribution as a 0 then I
don't go for N equals 2 and then this n
to the 1 half goes as 1 over N and then
since these are identical is tribute
that these are just n times K 2 and then
they cancel and I get 1 this is this is
what it should be because I normalized
so that the variance and they mean stay
fixed ok but then if I go for n larger
than 2 what will happen is that I will
have the same phenomena but instead of
getting this 1 over n I will get 1 over
N to the N halls and as soon as n is
bigger than 3 then this goes to 0 so
what this is proving is that the
limiting distribution should have
cumulants 1 0 sorry 0 1 0 0 0 0 for any
notion of independence and this proof of
course also goes for classical central
limit theorem provided as I have all
moments
so the definition of free cumulants is
of course we want the this is additive
with respect to free convolution so it
should be related to their transform
since they are transform is additive
with respect to free convolution then if
I take the coefficients of the series
expansion say when I have all moments
then this satisfies the result
properties the fact that it satisfies
the other properties is not so
complicated
maybe I want to emphasize the free they
permit Oriole approach to to free
convolution - yeah - to free convolution
and is given by the so-called moment
cumulant formula okay so this is
actually explain a little bit on what do
I mean by these two things
so by a non-crossing partition of size n
I mean I divide the subset 1 to N
in in subsets such that if I draw them
in the circle they do not cross okay so
a custom partition will be say is a
crossing partition this is what we don't
want okay and then if I have a partition
Sigma here
it's the partition 1 2 3
4-6 7-5 then a free cumulant will be
just the product of the sizes of the
blocks in this case it will be our three
times r2
this was formulas telling me is that if
I want to recover the cumulants from the
moments from the cumulants I used some
of our own custom partitions of size N
and then I do this multiplicative
application of the census of the blocks
okay so for instance mu1 is just our 1
and 2 is R 1 plus R sorry r2 plus r1
squared
so there is also a multiple advection of
cumulants which is just given by the
same formula and the difference is the
property of additive activity of
cumulant so for for one-dimensional
humans a trans is generalized to the
vanishing of mix cumulant so this should
be our what I'm saying here is that in
particular if I have only A's you saying
that is the mix if I take KN of a plus V
by the Multi multi linearity of the
chemo of of cumulants then I will have
this relation more general than the
previous one
so finally what is the relation between
random matrices and free probability so
we say that that two families let's say
two pairs of random variables in some
non community probability spaces
converge in distribution to a pair if
actually the moments or the joint
moments come back to the judge moments
of the limiting distribution okay and in
particular if this a and B are free we
said that these pairs converge so our
asymptotically free and the main example
comes from of course random ethicists
this notice very cool Isco is that if
one takes two Gaussian independent
matrices then as n goes to infinity
these two are asymptotically free with
respect to the respected trace and then
one can prove that this calls almost
surely
and another also important example is
when one takes a and B say deterministic
matrices meaning there is no randomness
and then I conjugate randomly with the
haar measure on the unit area and of
course this will have the same
distribution as a n but now there will
be somehow in three position okay and
the intuition is that when n is large
and and the the matrices are in random
position somehow I lose any relation
and these has been used to actually
predict the shape of matrices that we
can translate to calculations in free
probability for example here the
commutator and maybe for for for these
conference it is important or an
important example was that doesn't
follow from the previous one is when I
considered permutations so if I have to
permit random permutations they are
actually asymptotically free and this
explains somehow I the question
Mikhailov appear in image the result
just because D random regular graphs
somehow can be thought as the sum of n
random permutations and in fact the free
convolution of K 2 with itself gives a
these so-called question Michaela
I will just remind the basics about
finance the convolution I would go fast
Pattaya because so as I mentioned before
if I have a and B which are
deterministic and then I conjugate what
we typically used to do is to consider
the moments and then average take the
average of the moments and then what I
get is the eigenvalues
I will check my distribution of the song
and then the new approach isn't is not
to look at the distribution but look at
this crack is a characteristic
polynomial so what I'm doing is just
take exactly the same framework bootie
stead of taking expected moments I take
the respected coefficients of the
polynomial which surprisingly gives
another polynomial which is a real true
this is also of a mess and is exactly
what I'm saying here and of course if
this wants to be a definition one should
see that this was in depend on a and B
just as free convolution actually there
was very shy and explicit formula for
the coefficients of the financial
convolution and this was already solid
by worlds and others long time ago okay
so somehow what we're saying is that if
I have these coefficients and these
coefficients I go to this convolution
formula for the coefficients and here
these these factorials are actually play
a big role in the color
or the finite trickle multiplicative
convolution there's a similar one maybe
one of the applications of this or why
it was called finite free convolution is
that if one looks at their transform
instead of having an equality we have an
inequality and this was used to bound
the roots of the finite free convolution
of a with itself and maybe for a free
probabilists
I will be more interested in the fact
that proved by Marcos that when D goes
to infinity actually this inequality is
getting tighter and tighter and I get
somehow free convolution okay so what I
want to understand is which properties
from free probability already appear in
finite free convolution and in fact
maybe it can happen that the new
properties that we didn't know in free
probability can be can emerge from
properties that are known in that are
discovered in finite free convolution so
and then since I come from this finite
free comment approach then the first
question I ask myself is are there human
hands for this free convolution for this
one is free convolution and the
properties that I mentioned before can
be easily rephrase of course the first
one is that depth cumulants should be
somehow polynomial in the first moments
second is homogeneity
and here I need to know what is what
what does multiplying by constant means
and the TV one is exactly the same so
here just for one I replaced by one
prime and here I put it this not not a
monic polynomial with a polynomial with
with this coefficient in the median term
this is just for convenience
just because calculations are seen these
did I mention of of the polynomial so
it's a degree so the degree of the
polynomial so the dimension of the
matrix and what this means is that if so
what is the lambda of a polynomial is
just that I spread the polynomials by
multiplying by lambda so this means x
over 18 X over lambda
and of course the last one is the most
important and and is the same word okay
so if so there are let's say two
definitions of finite free cumulants the
favor the first one comes from from
their transform defined by Marcos which
was defined in this way but I liked more
in this way and one can easily prove
that this linearizes finally convolution
and observe here that I have a mole cs2
daddy meaning I chopped this series okay
and this is just like like because in
finite free convolution what we're doing
is almost like a multiplication of
polynomials but then chopped in the last
terms of my polynomial so if I will
start with the story then say the
definition will be of course the series
will be additive and then I will need to
take the coefficients of my series and
maybe the first theorem or the
definition which partitions looks as
follows
let me just try to explain a little bit
this formula okay so what I want is a
formula that involves partitions and
human lands and then some coefficient
which here is somehow complicated and I
will explain more about this polynomial
and how it behaves okay and the way one
proofs this is in two step two - somehow
simple steps one is first I go from
moments to coefficients and then they go
from coefficients to cumulants okay so
the two formulas that so what do these
formulas come from this comes from these
fish formula which is
no circle to get from a polynomial
coefficients to the moment it is just
going changing bases in this for the
symmetric functions so this is basically
Newton's identities
say what like mu zero sorry sorry this
is the mobis function in the partitions
this is just sorry in so if you want if
you have this formula I want to go from
this formula to this formula so there's
an inversion formula in general if you
have a partition some of your partitions
and this is exactly new
and we have also a coefficient -
chameleon for ball and then if I combine
them I get and I can prove easily with a
factorial pi is is just the product of
the sizes of the block the parentheses
Phi is so the dissenting factorial
Oh common descending toriel and then I
evaluate in and us in that way using
this actually this formula one can prove
that cumulants final equivalents are
additive without relying on Marco's
result directly and let me just analyze
a little bit what how this formula looks
like so first of all of all you see when
D goes to infinity one want to recover
free cumulants and from this formula is
not clear at all because somehow if one
if D goes to infinity so how you want to
see that here you have a d to the n plus
one put in this formula in fact D to the
N in this polynomial D to the N appears
in principle it is not trivial at all
that this polynomial is of the right
order and that the officiants are
correct so this is a lemma that in fact
and the other thing is that we don't hit
there's a typo we don't have in the
three cumulant formula we have
partitions which do not cross but we
have clear partitions all partitions so
we need to take care of these two things
okay and maybe the calculation or
proposition was actually to prove that
this is true and all proof is not very
nice we use induction on in and in fact
having a combinatorial proof of this
will be very nice okay so I mean that
this polynomial is of degree n plus 1
minus Sigma and that the leading
coefficient is this one assumed in this
proposition then why does finite free
cumulants approach free cumulants so the
reason is in fact that with this
proposition tells me that I can write
moments in terms of cumulants in first
in some in other partitions and then how
do I change from summing over partitions
to summon over Nkosi partitions well for
if each partition I need to divide by x
the number of no crushing partitions of
certain type and divide by the nominal
of partitions of this type and this is
actually exactly this coefficient so
this coefficient is not arbitrary
discuss an interpretation which is
exactly what I'm saying
the number of partitions of certain type
meaning with a fixed block structure
divided by the analog of the partitions
and and as you see a here I want to
mention that typically for example in
random matrices when Catalan numbers
appear typically we have like two types
of of of partitions one that got to zero
in in then large n limit and other ones
that go to one here it is not the case
so this kind of of asymptotic behavior I
don't think this was absurd before but I
want to say is that the reason why three
components finance the cumulants
approach free cumulants is very
different than the reason were example
that random matrices are asymptotically
free this community is like if there's
some mapping between not cross the
partition the regular purchase do you
mean a mapping that is like I guess it's
that do that I don't think so
this is the point like this is just a
coefficient that appears in the leading
term
and then the proof is just using exactly
this fact that I'm dead
and as I mention before we don't have a
very nice to commute or a proof of the
fact that this polynomial we have other
ways to write this polynomial for
example here is some other partitions
which join is is a total partition D to
the number of blocks of a row and here
the the modulus function 0 we have maybe
I don't know if this is if this is a
nicer formula or worse formula for the
moment Camille informal community really
but somehow it's as hard to handle as
the previous one
so maybe you just finished with some
applications and examples so why do we
why our cumulants useful it's not funny
mix cumulus because there's no actually
there's no finite thin dependence for
the moment so actually having finite
free convolution and finally three
multiplicative conclusion at the same
time seems to be hurting it's only very
specific example satisfy this so the
notion of independence should be first
table and then we can talk about mix
what one can try to use these cumulants
as and used to assume that mix cumulus
vanished but I don't think this is a
correct answer
so of course one can prove a central
limit theorem just as the way we did for
the freeze central limit theorem and
what we get is just a polynomial whose
cumulants are 0 1 and then 0 0 0 ok and
then when I place the moment Camille and
formula and when what one gets is
exactly that in fact one uses the
cumulant coefficient formula better and
what can one can get actually what are
the coefficients of my polynomial
explicitly and this is as Marcus proved
before this is just the MIT polynomial
one can also ask what is the analog of
the Poisson distribution
so the Poisson distribution is the
measure who has cumulants or lambda and
here one can actually calculate what is
the polynomial however it is not true
that for all lambda this is a polynomial
with real roots so this means that the
person is not infinitely divisible as in
the free case and in the classical case
what other things are in accordance with
reality for example that the atom of of
of the Poisson lambda is exactly the
same as in the free probability
so this is one question is we saw that
the Poisson doesn't satisfy what we it
should be which is infinity visibility
so one can ask about infinite
divisibility in finite free convolution
and the answer is somehow disappointing
because the only infinitely divisible
polynomial with respect to finite free
convolution is actually the one coming
from central limit theorem
after some reflection what happens is
that you cannot make many
infinitesimally limits so how one gets
for example the Poisson distribution the
Poisson distribution is the limit of the
law of small numbers but we cannot make
this kind of law in finally convolution
because polynomials do have at least one
over D of in each atom okay for for a
law of numbers we will need like 1 over
and for n very large so this will be
disappointing another property that is
true for in free convolution which is
not to true in classical convolution is
that in fact I can talk about MU T
meaning Mew to the power T for all T
bigger than 1 so this is the polynomial
whose column cumulants are T times the
original polynomial and while this is
not true that we can talk about T bigger
than 1 there is some T such that the
polynomial to the power T is not only a
real rooted but also has different roots
so this is somehow similar to pre
probability let me just point out that T
is not 1 we know this
I can give we can give a balance on how
large is T so how small is T but this
depends on D and this goes to infinity
when these two things so this doesn't
prove actually that the free version and
in fact the religion the proof of
mechanics Pike had really really cannot
be translated here because it it relies
on some relation between the
multiplicative convolution and an
additive convolution in fact free
additive convolution free multiplicative
convolution with projection this doesn't
hold we use more the approach of the
Commission by Klesko which is actually
the same paper of as the one where they
prove super convergence in fact what
they studied is somehow which functions
are are transforms of measure
we can also do averages interim
meaning what is the distance between the
end convolution to the central limit
theorem here the rate of convergence is
the same here the constants are terrible
also depends on the end is very large
and maybe used to finish is that another
thing that calls for finite free
probability that tossing holes for
classical probability but also for free
probability is called failure of
Kramer's theorem
meaning that in classical probability of
two measures adop gaussian distribution
then both of them should be Gaussian and
this is not true also for furniture
convolution let me just mention that all
these proofs provided that we have
cumulants are much easier in the finite
free version than in the free version
they're just like when I prove here
maybe we need some estimates but this is
not really really deep the mathematics
that are needed for this pure so I'm
really hoping that finally three
probability gives a lot of insight in
the probability for example yesterday I
talked they were talking about L meshes
okay how does this translate to free
probability well this translates in the
fact that if we have that we can bound
the density of the of the free
convolution in terms of the density of
the Commonwealth measures
but in this proposition the constant
goes to infinity and egos insanity I
cannot get that we should be more
precise on bounce
I I guess yes but only to work harder
the thing is that here actually the
proof is very simple somehow we didn't
work on the thing is that basically what
these constants are are large because
getting from cumulants to moments and
vice versa somehow it's very complicated
so we have positive and negative
coefficients which we are not able to
grasp very well
I do believe there is a constant it is
you look like a non-id version of the
various in result whether you take a
binary convolution of n different
polynomials the bounce will depend a
little bit on yeah as long as you see
here is exactly what is telling you at
least for this proof this is as long as
you can down the max of the cumulants
that's all
we are the Bombers to the nominee well
they have to have some dependence on
like how different the distributions are
I mean I know there's tight bounds that
recover the pipe down in the case where
they're all the same so in fact let me
just so factor here somehow the idea of
the proper burn is an issue the
following like if you have finite
variance and then the other moments
cannot be so large because you only have
D roots you cannot have many points very
very far because finite widens said
balance is one okay so at the end you
can bound where the roots are and this
can help you bound all of these guys so
somehow I don't think that the proof
would be very different
just retention
[Applause]